GILBERT STRANG: I would like
you to see the big picture
of linear algebra.
We're not doing, in
this set of videos,
a full course on linear algebra.
That's already on
OpenCourseWare 1806.
And now I'm concentrating
on differential equations,
but you got to see
linear algebra this way.
And this way means subspaces.
And there are four of
them in the big picture.
And we-- previous video
described the column space
and the null space.
Now, we've got two
more, making four.
And let me look at this
matrix-- it's for subspaces--
and put them into
the big picture.
So the first space I'll
look at is the row space.
Now, the row space
has these rows--
has the vector 1,
2, 3 and the vector
4, 5, 6, two vectors there,
and all their combinations.
That's the key idea in linear
algebra, linear combinations.
So 1, 2, 3 is a vector in
three dimensional space.
4, 5, 6 is another one.
Now, if I take all
their combinations,
do you visualize that if I have
two vectors, and I add them,
and I get another vector
that's in the same plane?
Or if I subtract them,
I'm still in that plane.
Or if I take five of one
and three of another,
I'm still in that plane.
And I fill the plane when I
take all the combinations.
So the row space-- can I
try to draw a picture here?
It's a plane.
This is the row space.
I'll just put row.
And in that plane are
the vectors 1, 2, 3
and the vectors 4,
5, 6, those two rows.
And the plane fills
our combinations.
Well, I can't draw am infinite
plane on this MIT blackboard.
But you get the idea.
It's a plane.
And we're sitting
in three dimensions.
Now, the other--
so there's more.
We've only got one-- a
plane here, a flat part,
like a tabletop,
extending to infinity,
but not filling 3D because
we've got another direction.
And in that other direction
is the null space.
That's the nice thing.
So I would like to know the
null space of that matrix.
I'd like to solve so the
null space, N of A-- I'm
solving Av equals all 0s.
So some combination
of those three columns
will give me the 0 column.
Let me write it
in as a 0 column.
What could v be?
What combination of that column,
that column, and that column
give 0, 0?
Now, I know there are some
interesting combinations
because I-- only amounts to two
equations with three unknowns,
v1, v2, v3.
I want to multiply that by
v1, that by v2, that by v3.
So I have three unknowns,
but I've only two 0s
to get, only two equations.
And if I have three
unknowns and two equations,
there will be lots of solutions.
And I can see one.
Do you see that if I add
that and that, I get 4, 10
And that's the same-- 4, 10
is the same as 2 times 2, 5.
In other words, I
believe v equal--
if I took 1 of the first
and 1 of the third,
and if I subtracted 2
of the second column--
so Av will give me 1
of the first column, 1
of the third column,
and subtracting
2 of the second column
will give me 0, 0.
So here's my null space.
My null space heads
off in this direction,
in the direction
of 1, minus 2, 1.
But, of course, I
get more solutions
by multiplying v by any number.
10 times that vector would
still give me 0s and still
be in the null space.
So I really have--
the null space
is a whole line of vectors.
It's that vector and any
multiple of that vector.
So it's a whole infinite line,
which is a one dimensional
subspace, the null space.
So the null space
in my picture--
here is the null space.
Well, it is not very thick is
it because it's just a line.
So I'll call this
N of A, this line.
Well, you see I'm trying to
draw a three dimensional space.
That line goes both ways.
But it's perpendicular
to the plane.
That's the fabulous part.
That's wonderful.
This line, the null space, is
perpendicular to this plane,
the row space.
You want to know why?
You want to just see it?
Because if I take A
times v, that would be 1,
2, 3 times v. 1, 2, 3 is
perpendicular to that.
How do I check perpendicular
for two vectors?
1, 2, 3 dot product.
1, minus 2, 1, the dot product
is 1 times 1, minus 2 times
2-- that's 4-- plus
3 times 1, that's 3.
1 minus 4 plus 3 is 0.
And, similarly, 4
minus 10 plus 6 is 0.
So this is a right angle here.
It's a right angle, 90 degrees
between those two subspaces.
And again, in this
example, one space
is two dimensional, a plane.
The other space is one
dimensional, a perpendicular
line.
I can show with my
hands, but I can't
draw on this flat blackboard.
I have the plane
going infinitely far,
and I have the line
going perpendicular to it
and meeting, of course,
at 0-- at the 0 vector.
That solves Av equals
0, and it also-- it's
a combination, a 0
combination of the rows.
That's half of the big
picture, the row space
and the null space.
Now, I'm ready for
the other half, which
is a second side of the
other-- the right-hand side
of the big picture contains
the column space first of all.
So what's the column
space of that matrix?
So the column space
of a matrix, we
take all combinations
of those three columns.
And that will fill out a space.
Now, I have-- so I
take the vector 1, 4.
And I take the vector
2, 5, maybe there.
And then I'm going to
also take the vector 3, 6.
Well, I've got three columns.
So I'm counting out 3, up 6.
Good.
Take those combinations of those
vectors, and what do you get?
This is a picture in
two dimensional space
because these columns are in
two dimensions, 1,4; 2, 5; 3, 6.
When I take the combinations
of 1, 4 and 2, 5,
those are in
different directions.
The combinations already give
me all of two dimensional space,
so the column space is the
whole space, including 0,
0 because I could take 0 of
1 plus 0 of the other vector.
And that third column can't
contribute anything new.
It's sitting in
the column space.
It's a combination of those two.
But the first two
are independent.
Their combinations
give the whole plane.
So the column space
is the whole plane.
Column space.
There's not much room
for our fourth subspace.
But the fourth subspace, in
this example, is quite small.
Let me tell you about the
fourth subspaces then.
So we know the
null space, N of A.
And we know the column space,
C of A. The null space was
in this picture.
The column space
was in that picture.
Now, what about-- what's
the name for the row space?
Well, if I transpose the
matrix, the row space
turns into the column space.
Transpose rows into columns
of the matrix A transpose.
So by transposing a matrix,
it turns these two rows
into two columns.
And that's what I have here.
The row space is the--
this is the column
space of the transpose matrix.
I like it.
I don't want to introduce a
new letter for the row space.
I like having just column
space and null space.
So I-- and I'm OK to
go to A transpose.
Now, what's that fourth guy?
Oh, just by beautifulness,
general principles of elegance
here.
If I have columns space
and null space of A,
and if I have column
space of A transpose,
the fourth guy has to be the
null space of A transpose.
Sorry, I wrote that
so small, so small.
But I did write this
a little larger.
The null space of A
transpose, all the w's
that solve that equation.
A transpose w equals 0.
The null space of A
transpose is all the w's that
solve that equation.
What does that
equation looks like?
Ha!
Well, that equation--
A transpose
will have two columns.
So A transpose-- this will
be w1 of the first column.
1, 2, 3, when I transpose.
And w2 of the second column,
4, 5, 6 equaling 0, 0, 0.
Well, now I've got, for this
null space-- because my matrix
here is 2 by 3, for
this fourth subspace,
I have three equations and
only two unknowns, w1 and w2.
And, in fact, the
only solutions are
w1 equals 0, w2 equals
0, because that's
the only way I can get
combination-- that's
the only combination
of that vector
and that vector that gives
me 0 is to take 0 of that
and zero of that.
Do you see that the-- in
this example, the null space
of A transpose is just--
null space of A transpose--
is just what I call
the 0 subspace.
The subspace that has
only one puny vector
in it, the 0 vector.
But that's OK.
It follows the
rule for subspaces.
And it completes the
picture of four subspaces.
In other examples, we could
have all four subspaces nonzero.
But we would have two over
here that, together, complete
the full N dimensional space.
And over here, we have two that
together complete the full M
dimensional space.
And here, for this matrix, M was
2, so that this is completed.
The column space was
all of R2 in this case.
All of two dimensional
space was the column space,
and that didn't leave any
room for the left null space,
the null space of A transpose.
So do you see that picture?
Let we may be just sketch it
once more with a clean board.
So I have the row space.
Let me draw it maybe going
this way, the row space.
And perpendicular to
that is the null space.
That's in-- we're
here in N dimensions,
and they are perpendicular,
those spaces.
And then, over here, I
have the column space.
And perpendicular to that
is the left null space.
And we're here in M dimensions.
Those are our four subspaces.
And they have-- they sit in N
dimensional space, two of them,
two of them in M dimensional
space, perpendicular.
And I could tell you something
about their dimensions.
So this row space, in that
example, was two dimensional.
It was a plane.
In general, the
dimension equals--
let's say R. That's an important
number, the rank of A. Oh,
that's a key number.
Maybe, I better speak separately
about the rank of a matrix.
But I'll complete the idea here.
So the dimension
of the row space
is the number of
independent rows.
And I call that number
R. And the beauty
is that this has
the same dimension.
Dimension Is also
the rank R. Can
I say that wonderful
fact in a sentence?
The column space and the row
space have the same dimension.
The number of independent
rows equals the number
of independent columns.
That's like a miracle for a
giant matrix, say 57 by 212,
there might be 40
independent rows.
Then, there would be
40 independent columns.
And then the null space
and the left null space
have the remaining dimension.
So the null space has dimension
N minus R because, altogether--
together they have dimension N.
And this has dimension M minus
R because, together, they
have dimension M. That's the
picture with the dimensions put
in.
And let me say a little more
about the idea of dimension
in a separate video.
Thank you.